Speaker 1: Let's go next to Quinn from
Dallas, Texas. Quinn, you're on the air.
Speaker 3: Oh, hello, David. Thanks for
taking calls in. This is my first time
calling in. My pleasure. Yeah, absolutely. I
actually wanted to ask you one thing. So I'm
a little younger. I'm a freshman in college
right now. And I was wondering kind of about
the messaging that we have as liberals, leftists,
progressives, whatever you want to call us. Yeah,
I'm sure a lot of the same views as my friends
that are further left than me. But I find that a
lot of my peers in college are only on the right
because they disagree with the further left,
which obviously I hear more about. So do you
think it's going to be more beneficial like in
the future for, I mean, politicians one and
just people in general to kind of stick to,
I guess, somewhere in between what we have in
office and then like promoting socialism, that
kind of thing, somewhere in between those two?
Speaker 1: Well, even even those as the as the
lines are arbitrary and probably not necessarily
accurate. I mean, it's why would you say that
it should be between those two poles?
Speaker 3: So for me personally, I have
a lot of interaction where what happens is the
only reason I have one of my classmates disagree
in terms of the political efficacy when they're
trying to convince people of things is because
they say, oh, well, you on the left want to get
rid of, like our entire structural system. And
then they go into the whole I mean, anti trends,
anti whatever, immigration, that kind of thing.
So taking the most extreme positions and
then garnering those is the ones that
I guess most progressives hold. I think that
Speaker 1: is a better approach then than maybe
creating some new arbitrary middle between two
extremes or two two places on the political
spectrum that may not even accurately reflect
the vast majority of the population. It would
be more interesting just to immediately
correct when people start arguing against
some far left socialist view of what the left
wants to immediately say. There are very few
actual socialists in the United States and even
fewer actual socialists in position of power.
Can you tell me which elected official wants
that? Which elected official says that the
means of production should be seized, which
elected officials at the federal level are
actual socialist? Put it back on them. And because
there aren't any or almost any, if you look at
city councils and stuff like that, they would be
unable to. I think that that's a better approach.
Speaker 3: Absolutely. Yeah, that helps a lot.
I think definitely because a lot of cases what
you're seeing now is there's so much overlap in
the general consensus on policy positions. Yeah.
And it's genuinely just the identity of what side
you fall on that kind of is determining how people
are voting. And then I guess one more question.
So I'm really interested in moving abroad. Right.
I've always wanted to move to Germany because I've
been learning German for the past three years.
And my question is, what do you think is kind
of the best method for Americans who really
do care about the direction of the country
when it comes to kind of promoting their
views or their I don't want to say agenda,
but from, I guess, a foreign perspective,
Speaker 1: you're saying if you went
to Germany, what could you best do to
promote your view of American politics in
Speaker 3: Germany? Exactly. Because
I feel like when I move, I'm kind of I don't
want to say abandoning, but leaving, you know,
a part of my country in the sense that I won't
be able to have the same change. It's kind of OK.
There are problems we have here, and that's kind
of why I do want to move. So I feel like I'm
abandoning those problems and just running
away from them because they're hard to do.
Speaker 1: I mean, listen, you kind of
are I hate to say it, but the best the
best way to achieve change in the United
States is to stay in the United States and
fight for it with social media and
digital activism. You can be in Germany,
you could be phone banking more than anybody in
the US is. Right. So I think there are things
that you can do. But I think it's important
to recognize, like moving to Germany is not
how you achieve change in the United States. It's
totally fine for you to move to Germany. I have
no problem with you doing it and at a certain
point saying I've had enough and I'm bailing.
It's you know, ultimately we've got to live
our lives. I think I'm not attacking that.
But I think in a sense, you're going to be much
better able to achieve change in the U.S. if
you're in the U.S. than if you're in Germany.
Speaker 3: Yeah, you're absolutely right. And
also, that would completely change your chances of
running later because they would say, oh, you left
the country. You don't really, you know. Yeah, to
Speaker 1: some degree that may be true if your
plan is to get into politics personally. Yeah,
but listen, I think it sounds like it'll be
fascinating to be in Germany for a period. I'm
going. In Germany, actually, in August myself.
Speaker 3: Oh, that's so cool. Well,
I hope you enjoy your time there.
I definitely will be calling it again.
So thanks for taking my call. Yeah.
Speaker 1: All right. My pleasure. Thanks
very much, Quinn. Very nice collar.